[Music]
so it's a 11 o'clock we are now almost
driving around one hour for puffin
Patrol security thing here this one this
one this one's be careful yes we got one
if you give me the net come here
yeah yeah yeah yep got it
my goodness you are drama queen you had
drama queen yes everything is fine now
you're happy
[Music]
can even land the place and delay and
the ocean is just as much a character in
our lives as your brother or sister you
know we've always been that way because
we're isolated for an island everything
here is so interconnected and people
feel that because they had to it was the
only way they could survive
[Music]
less than two kilometers from the
coastlines of witless Bay is the witless
bait ecological reserve it's a group of
islands that spread out from the witless
Bay region and they're home to the
Atlantic puffin new feelin's iconic bird
there's over 600 thousand pairs of
puffins on these islands they mate every
year they go to sea for four years and
when they come back they keep coming
here there's records showing that we
have coffins that are up to 20 and 30
years old there and they come to the
same Burroughs so it's really important
that this ecological reserve was
established to protect these birds
[Music]
if you look around the community now
they advertise it the home of the
Atlantic puffin and some of their
facilities are named after a puffin the
school mascot is a puffin so is
something that people are proud of
everybody can resonate with them the
puffin generates a lot of revenue in
tourism in Newfoundland and especially
in this local area and it creates a lot
of jobs that's a big icon for tourism in
Newfoundland puffin it's our provincial
bird you know so you know they we've got
really got to look after them
it has sort of always been a thing we
would see the birds squat all over the
road and different things and we just be
knew obviously they were confused but we
didn't know anything about that until
into the 2000s that's when we started to
learn what the problem was it could have
been many people who came into our town
and started the paw patrol and there
would have been resistance because it
would have been the whole you're an
outsider how are you telling us what to
do but this is unique because it was
Jurgen and you want to look me in the
camera right yeah I - you okay okay
that's good his presence is fast and
it's very open everybody knows you're
good
when I go to the post office or the shop
they say hey puffin man and I think it's
a compliment I wouldn't call me in real
environmentalist because I know people
who do is this too much more than than
what I'm doing is but we just taking
care as I learned it I think it's normal
to do a sink sexist when you see
something it's wrong try to change it I
[Music]
meant you're gonna like time was all he
was in filmmaking and he had quite a an
array of movie stars he's his own
character he beats his own drum and I
loves this air it's like champagne yes
it's it's so wonderful here I'm so
grateful when we're all so grateful that
he came in he saw the situation and
people just then started to come
together and just feel good about doing
something for their community
I want to know tonight it's puffins
patrol again are you ready it was in
August in L famiiy we watched on the
road dead little birds during the day
you're gonna often finds other puffins
on the witless Bay rogues who are not so
lucky
every year hundreds of young puffins
those birds with colourful beaks lose
their way in the waters off Newfoundland
and Labrador ending up on a wing and a
prayer
the little puffins have been getting
lost in town so I was asking people here
around what is it and they told me don't
touch in there person has been always
there but I thought something is wrong
what could it be
and then you find out that this little
dead bird on the road our little puffin
chicks we learnt as they come out in the
night and they look for light moonlight
in their instance but they have no idea
is a new light traffic light or car
light or garage light whatever it is
they sing light is like let's go for it
so there's my dentist and in the middle
of the road signal truly hit by a car my
wife
Elfi and myself we just thought let's do
something and we did it I put this on
the trees and on the sign on the road
that people no other night
where can we deliver the preference and
we're the headquarters and then I put
this one here they are eliminated for
the cars you can put them on the car you
need always a chart good name of doing
something and perfect role saves
everything powerful patrol didn't down
unnecessary light so we started to by
Bluffs with my gloves butterfly nets in
the car I do have the net in a
flashlight and elfia me went out the
first time to save the little birds so
we go from the flesh that from the left
side with a net from the right side the
bird look of the flesh that I go from
the left side and there we got it we put
them then in a little cradle lets him
here and next table it then go
we drove from nine o'clock to almost one
o'clock in the night my smart wife to a
Burin there's not enough we should not
do this alone we should bring in some
people and then it start rolling
it's ten o'clock it depends every day
how many do we saving it could be 10 it
could be 20 every night out we put them
in a little cradle and then the next
morning is the release driving around
you're walking around or low years100
sometimes 800-900 driving 1 o'clock to 2
o'clock and people wear nothing on my
door or bringing birth in front of the
door
driving around or walking around I'm
saying we saved over in total more than
10 pounds
sometimes the whole shed was full camera
on mine wait wait wait it's too much to
beak for me applause
we were so happy that we have now this
spread to Canadian Park and we're in a
society and they decided to take over
the puffins Patrol as their issue I
don't think we can ever fill your
confuse so thank you for coming out when
you have a program like this you start
to find out in your community who is
conservation minded who maybe they feel
that this isn't an issue my name is
Suzanne Dooley
I with the Canadian parks and wilderness
Society we have coordinate and
facilitate this program to this day even
though it's a-you know seems to be a
very good news story still there is a
bit of opposition as well we can't
please everybody
but I know there is a lot of opposition
within community for and against like
every project some of our core
volunteers that we have they see that
and they feel that as well too sometimes
the problems makes the national news for
all the wrong reasons that was the case
last week and what is an ironic twist
witness Bay did indeed make the national
news because of what looked like an
effort of silence of citizens on social
media witness made Town Council had
unanimously passed a motion to look into
retaining independent criminal lawyer to
review a recent social media accusations
against the current Town Council that
didn't sit very well with Laurel Yard
who has been embroiled in a battle with
Council over the development of ragged
Beach lorna joins me live the studio
it's nice to see you lorna my reputation
in town well i probably wouldn't want to
imagine this but i don't know i just
have to think of her there for a second
i was surprised by the question
I think Lorna wouldd described herself
as an activist Lorna is very much
involved in the local community because
she's a fighter and she fights for the
environmental and I know that she is one
of the strong opponents of the ragged
Beach group and actually has a Facebook
page she runs the ragged Beach News line
which is all the news about the what's
going on and so forth I have this streak
in me where I just I do stand up for
things I believe in and so I never
really got involved in a puff control
too much until the ragged Beach threat
happened
[Music]
so ragged beach is a dark coast right
now there are no houses there is no
light pollution and it is directly
across from the ecological reserve and
it would never occur to us to build a
house there because if you put in a
development and the coastline I believe
and many of us believe it will be
absolutely catastrophic for the reserve
but when you get people coming in from
outside they just view a piece of land
and say wow this is amazing
I would like to live here and so we have
a group of people floating so hard for
what we see as the benefits of
protecting our environment are
protecting the puffins and then we have
people who are really just concerned
with profits and monetizing coastlines
oh there are some berries
[Music]
not quite ripe but some are more than
others so my name is Ann Marie Churchill
I'm a landowner here in the Ragan Beach
area and a Newfoundlander yeah so I grew
up in Newfoundland and I grew up about
30 minutes from here in the city of st.
John's and so when we came back we just
really wanted to be close to the ocean
in nature so that's how we ended up here
we actually were hiking here one day and
looked it up when we got home and there
was land for sale we were told from the
very beginning there will be a group
there who are going to oppose you they
proposed in the past anyone who's tried
to develop in this area because they
don't want any houses down here but it's
private property so we thought okay well
we'll deal with it what do we need to do
to make this okay like what do you want
and they said we're not here to
negotiate we're here to stop you we want
no development down here when the
Churchill's put in their application in
2010 to have that resumed at the time
there was just a collective scream of
outrage from the province from the world
and so this right here is ragged beach
so you can see that this is directly
across now here you'll see this is
witless Bay and here you'll see this
subdivision back here so if you look at
this subdivision and you look at ragged
beach you can see how close rageh
beaches and you just look straight out
if you're looking straight at the
witless bay ecological reserve the
island is directly across from us we
live in a town of 1,200 people and our
Town Council got over 1,400 letters
against rezoning that area they got 11
in support I have here a letter from
Bill Monta Vicki bill is he is a seabird
biologist he's known the world over that
of all the ecological seabird reserves
in Newfoundland and Labrador the witless
bay ecological reserve is the one in
closest proximity to coastal communities
and is the one most at risk to human
activities and development this is a
letter from a descendant of a wittle
spay resident this is a man who lives in
New York a subdivision with more to come
and
a kingly beautiful stretch of coastline
in Newfoundland beautiful not just
because our eyes tell us so but because
our hearts do as well and those letters
were just ignored and that's when the
[Applause]
[Music]
local town council here does not
subscribe to issues of environmentalism
or sustaining our natural assets our
local council their mandate is
development big development big business
that's their mandate where there's more
development there's more lights and so
we want to protect rageh Beach there are
subdivisions in which this pay is
averring
in all communities and I think when you
start new projects rotary you look back
on and say well I wish I'd done
something a little bit different
clear-cutting maybe in a couple of the
divisions here some business may have
been excessive but there is something to
be said for the private landowners that
live within the line of fire
Who am I to say that they can't build
and I'm an individual resident I'm not
speaking from the council so yeah I mean
I don't I wouldn't speak against I think
it's insane that it seems to me any
reasonable person that would walk down
on that beach and say let's put up some
houses it's got something wrong with
their thinking I'm shocked the first
time they called us developer and I
think this group know that that's a word
that gets people so they've used it
they've called us the developers know
we're landowners that's what I call me
I'm a landowner and I want a house on my
left I would say absolutely it's not a
story of development versus environment
I think it is a story of legitimate
environmental causes being hijacked to
stop some private landowners in a small
area new friend from using their land
their argument is if we put a house here
then we're adding lighting and we're
adding development to the area and my
argument is that Newfoundlanders have
always built along the shoreline but it
can be done respectfully in this town
people have built lots of development
but what we've done here is a thousand
times different we didn't clear-cut at
the most we get a gazebo or a house for
our boys that's it
I don't want some trees not on hotels I
want peace I feel I'm an
environmentalist so I've had to question
myself is this gonna hurt the birds I
don't believe one house is I do all my
thinking this is where I come when I'm
feeling a [ __ ]
the puffins have been hijacked like I
used to love the puffins cause now I
hear it and I almost get nauseated
because I know it's been hijacked by
people who know how to do it who are
good marketers who are good sellers who
do use social media so we have been
vilified this has been put on Facebook
that were horrible people and they spin
something to get their own way
[Music]
[Music]
there's always in small towns personal
conflicts and usually they settle it
over a period of time but right now
because of social media and Facebook
there there seems to be quite a lot of
texting and tweeting going on the scary
part is that that amplification is
dangerous like someone said oh they
don't own that land we'll burn down
their gazebo and I worry about that
because if you get people who don't
think things through or may not be
stable that could happen like I think
there could be real consequences and
I've said that this continues to go on
and somebody's going to get hurt you
[Music]
know I haven't always acted honorably
and there have been times when
frustration and stress got to be you
know puffins can't speak for themselves
rocks and beaches can speak for
themselves and we're not my head screwed
on straight that's up for debate but my
intentions are true
so we're going that we're driving down
galas Co Road here now I'm gonna say
we're gonna go down to rag of each it's
at the very end of this road I always
draw my strength and my comfort from
ragged Beach and so that's why I feel so
strongly so if I come here a lot in the
fall and generally in the offseason but
during the summer not so much anymore
just because of the whole situation
surrounding I can't stay reasonable and
rational and and I don't want to lose
control I don't want to be upset and
angry all the time I want to be
reasonable and they want to understand
where they're coming from
so my fantasies will work together I
don't think that will happen so as you
can see where we're right at the feet of
the ecological reserve were directly
across from it so our position is that
if you put development in here I mean
it's gonna be shining right at the
reserve and we're already facing a lot
of challenges all the time I don't hate
you we agreed in holy cow he's pretty
wild when you don't have never met us we
didn't start the fire thing oh well we
bought mint and then it went personal so
I'm just saying you don't know us so
it'd be great to get to know each other
sometimes but you know when you bought
the land you knew you couldn't build
here it's not true we have I have a
quote in a newspaper that you said this
I have we have approval in principle
from the land we had a lawyer
investigate and you've written that you
even saw we had the approval in
principle but that that's beside the
point at this point I am asked
environmentalist one house up here as
far as wave we've offered to be given
another hundred feet from the trail will
that have any impact on the birds and
the answer was three houses in an
environment Enclave will not hurt it
hurt the birds whatsoever you can't tell
me
that one house back here with and hooded
lights environmentally sensitive is
hurting the Poppins I think what you're
doing is you're hijacking the puffins in
the East Coast rail to keep this line
later private and Michelle Dickey that's
what I she flipped out this is what you
do you do all this personal stuff I
don't even hope miss Chelios I have no
idea and you're talking about but you
just said that tomorrow you'll have
found Facebook that we are somehow in
with someone doing something weird you
guys have given everything people you've
arrested because I sat in the courtroom
when I views don't please I think when
you make fun you know what actually I'm
not even gonna add sex that's not true I
heard you guys I urge we didn't even
know who's on the stamp honored you have
no idea what we're talking about that's
what I mean what you do instead of the
facts you go personal you try to destroy
people but we're not willing to give up
our land right man
it's the town you don't get it about ten
times or anything me but you're the one
doing this attacking this isn't brash
nice what am i attacking you now when
I'm telling you you can use your land as
you always used it as it was designated
you have no access and that's just the
paratime story it doesn't get any better
than that Lorna
that is
[Music]
I think this is a very very important
place for nature and for the animals but
as always when you are in the middle of
the I our secret you're not seeing the
whole thing so it's something worth
fighting for something we're dying for
how almost they think that they're gonna
where the people who want to preserve
that down it's not going to happen it's
a battle for me that's not going to end
and I don't think it's going to end for
a lot of other people well I think when
you have controversy there always be
aside of it that's you know that's
sensationalized I would hope that we can
find a common ground for all groups that
have concerns that someday soon we can
get those concerns out and discussing
and come to terms with
I have invested a lot personally and
there's times it's been really really
tough to the point where you know I had
episodes of really severe depression and
there were times when I just said to
myself and everybody else I'm dawn I'm
dawn and you just come back but you know
there's also been really amazing things
too you know friendships have been made
but at the end of the day it's not about
me it's about ragga Beach
it's about puffins it's about wildlife
it's about the spectacular reserve
that's what it's about I don't know I
mean maybe I'll change my mind maybe
they will push us out of here but I
would feel bad about that I feel like we
need to hold our ground
but try to keep it civilized I talk to
people more but I'm trying to be helpful
about it let people know the truth and
ignore social media I don't know where
to go with that so I kind of have some
hope if we could hold out the ecological
system is so sensitive here it is over
here it's really here you can feel it
you can see but we are there paw patrol
and all the organization we try to
protect it and it's growing it's doing
well like what's your dream situation
let me quote Jack Nicholson heat or be
Jurgen in a perfect world everything
would be really perfect but we are not
in a perfect world so what can I do what
can I change of course I do want to stop
the perfect world of course I will not
see any dead birds anymore of course I
would like to have people respect and
things like this but the world isn't so
you know it is as it is so
[Music]
[Music]